شحنته الاسلحه المهربه تكاد لا تتوقف في
اتجاه جماعه الحوثي في اليمن مره اخرى في
خليج عمان البحريه الفرنسيه تضبط زورقا
يضم اكثر من 3000 بندقيه فضلا عن نصف
مليون رصاصه و20 صاروخا مضادا للدبابات
العمليه جاءت في وقت اصبحت باريس
دورا اكبر في عمليه التصدي لتهرب الاسلحه
في المنطقه بعد ان تصدرت واشنطن المهمه
اكد ان الجيش الامريكي ساعد في مصادره
الشحنه
وخلال شهرين تمكنت واشنطن وشركائها من منع
وصول اكثر من 5000 قطعه سلاح ومليون و600
الف طلقه ذخيره الى اليمن البحريه
الامريكيه كانت قد صادرت اكثر من 2000
بندقيه من قارب في خليج عمان كانت متجهه
الى جماعه الحوثي اضافه الى مخدرات تبلغ
قيمتها 33 مليون دولار من سفينه صيد في
المياه الدوليه في خليج عمان الشحنه
المهربه من الاسلحه الى اليمن ليست والده
اليوم في ديسمبر الماضي اعلنت البحريه
الامريكيه مصادره
1400 بندقيه من طراز اي كي 47 من علامات
سفينه صيد شماليه بحر العرب كانت قادمه من
ايران كما صدرت اكثر من مليون ومئه الف
طلقه من سفينه صيد تعمل بين ايران واليمن
منذ انقلاب ميليشيه الحوثي في اليمن اواخر
عام 2014 كشفت ايران عمليات تهريب الاسلحه
جوا وبرا وبحرا وعبر كل
المنافذين العربيه